سها جميل البدايه اليوم والله عاد سبقناش
واكلنا فلافل اليوم بس شكله الفلافل زاكي
حواليك صباح الخير الريحه واصله لعنا
يعني الصباح صباح الورد الرائحه فعلا
الرائحه فعلا تسبق الصوره للاسف لا يمكننا
نقل الرائحه من اعرق
لا يهمك صنع الفلافل ولكن بالنسبه لهذه
الوجبه
اكيد بالنسبه لهذه الوجبه وجبه الفلافل
وما يخصني انا كنباتيه يعني افضل هذه
الوجبه لانها تتيح فرصه كبيره لتناول شيء
يعني يناسبني كنباتيه يوم امس كان اليوم
العالمي للفلافل سمي على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بعنوان انترناشونال فلافل دي
خرج الكثير من مشاهير السوشيال ميديا من
رواد المواقع هذه في تناول وجبه الفلافل
يعني هي وجبه تقليديه ربما اردنيا وعربيا
وحتى باتت وجبه دوليه يعني وجبات الفلافل
في الاردن هي تؤكل لوحدها وتؤكل ضمن
سندويشات هنا في الاردن تصنع بالحمص وربما
في مصر تصنع في الفول وتسمى الطعميه وبغض
النظر عادل وراوي عن الاسماء فعلا تستحق
هذه الوجبه التقليديه يعني مظاهاتا مع
المنسف ولا مقارنه ولكن ان تاخذ حيزا يعني
من من رغبه الناس في تذوقها والاستمتع
فيها والخبر الاخر ايضا عادل وراويه يخص
ايضا مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يعني هناك
ارقام صادمه بان اكثر من 300 مشهور على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي باختلافها
يتقادون سنويا مئه الف دينار اردني هذه
ارقام كبيره يعني باتت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هي مصدر رزق او مهنه او حرفه
بات العديد من الناس يعتمدوها في ان يعني
يتمكنون من ان يحصلون على مدخول لهم مستوى
شهري او سنوي بغض النظر عادل وراويه عن عن
المحتوى المقدم ولكن شئنا ام ابينا مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي باتت تفرض نفسها وفي
الاردن خاصه رغم ايضا دعيني اقول نقطه ان
التيك توك هنا في الاردن تم توقيفه لانه
عرض بعض محتوى لم يتناسب ربما مع الدوله
الاردنيه وبالتالي تم ايقافه ولكن مشاهير
السوشل في ميديا في الاردن مستمرين على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعرض محتواهم
وهناك العديد من المتابعات وباتت هذه
المنصه يعني يعني مصدر رزق للجميع
وبالتالي ضريبه الدخل في الاردن باتت
تلاحق هذه هؤلاء المشاهير لفرض ضريبه بعد
هذه الارقام الفلكيه
والمدخول الكبير اسم جديد الان سيشاهد
السوشيال ميديا في الاردن
في مصالح الضرائب بشكل عام في كل الدول
قسم السوشيال ميديا شكرا جزيلا لك مراسله
صباح العربيه سهى جميل كانت معنا من عمان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات